before we start today's episode check
this out it's our brand new
what if 100 book it features the 100
most popular what-if scenarios
as suggested by you learn more and get
this special collector's piece
by clicking in the link in the
description below
410 kilometers above the earth
that's where the international space
station floats
oh my goodness i think i'm gonna be sick
what if you happened to be all the way
up here
but suddenly fell off and had to skydive
down to earth what would happen
[Music]
is something like this possible
how fast would you travel from this
height
and what would happen once you got back
to earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you skydived
from the iss the highest skydive in the
world
happened from 38 kilometers from earth
the skydiver reached a speed of over
1300
per hour and was in free fall for nearly
four minutes and 20 seconds
our jump from the iss would be
10 times as high as that one
what would happen once you jumped off
[Music]
well once you jumped off it wouldn't be
a simple descent down to the ground
that's because
the iss is moving at 27
600 kilometers per hour that's
around 30 times faster than a commercial
airplane
and if the iss is moving at this speed
you would be too so instead of going
straight down to the ground
you'd be circling the earth while moving
at this velocity
you could potentially circle it for
years before your velocity decreased
enough
to descend down but since we only have a
couple of minutes left in the video
we're going to give you a jet pack with
just enough fuel
to stop the velocity ah much better
but just because we've stopped you from
going so fast
doesn't mean this skydive would be any
easier
thanks to earth's gravitational pull
you'd now
be thrust towards the planet's surface
instead of around it
as you've plummeted down to the earth's
surface you'd be moving at
over 2 000 kilometers per hour depending
on your weight
and at this speed you would be
experiencing
over six g-forces during the longest
skydive ever
the diver involved experienced four
g-forces
that's comparable to a pretty intense
roller coaster
and fighter pilots experience six
g-forces when flying their jets
but that takes a lot of practice and
only happens for
short periods suddenly experiencing 6
g-forces with no prior practice would
feel
like the most intense thrill ride of
your life
and this would only be the start of your
speed
as you move through the earth's
atmosphere your momentum would continue
to increase
you'd be moving so fast that you'd
compress the air in front of you
causing it to heat up to temperatures as
high as 1600 degrees
as you continued heading toward earth
you'd be experiencing more
and more g-forces this would be like
having
eight times the amount of gravitational
force you'd typically experience on
earth
this kind of energy would likely cause
you to lose consciousness
your blood vessels would burst and your
organs would be shifting around
this pain would be incredibly
excruciating
but if you could hold out for just a bit
longer
your velocity would begin to slow down
as the density of the air
increased giving you more resistance
if you somehow managed to wake up around
this time
at around 2500 meters above sea level
you could deploy a parachute and now
you could enjoy the sights as you come
down to earth
just remember that once you land you'd
need to get
medical help immediately
you'd likely have some internal bleeding
and maybe some broken bones due to all
that gravitational pressure you just
experienced
but what if you weren't lucky enough to
have a parachute and
fell out of an airplane without one well
that sounds like a story for another
what if